want to know what's heating up theaters  this weekend is this good right foot  taking the law into his own hands  a surgeon becomes a vigilante after his  wife and daughter are viciously attacked  in death wait give me a choice die or  become a sparrow in red sparrow a young  woman becomes a Russian intelligence  officer and is then forced to use her  body as a weapon anything this is what  you want men to call I'm sorry I did not  think that that's what that was about in  submission a college professor becomes  obsessed with a talented young student  endangering his marriage and his career  free now what's it gonna cost me see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  fantasy patient so what's your weekend  ticket going to be let us know by  commenting see you next time on weekend  ticket  [Music]